at 5 000 people have had their right to  vote challenge because of the law passed  by Brian Kemp  so obviously it's all nonsense but even  just take the individual claims that  she's making she's saying Brian Kemp is  stealing the election by not providing  people food and water while they wait to  vote do you think do you think the The  Ballot Box is a Michelin rated  restaurant since when do we get food and  water at the at the polls I don't  remember that I voted in every election  I could vote in in my life I've never  gotten uh yes I'll have the steak tartar  please I'll start with the state tartar  then I would like to move on to a nice I  don't know maybe an Ahi Tuna could I get  thank you so much yeah so just bring it  back to me in line while I maybe a glass  of uh Dom Perignon would be good too no  what are you talking about  they're rigging the vote because they're  not serving you a meal what on Earth are  you talking about